We just got up and took a shower.
We are about to go to the dojo.
We did not sleep very well so we are a bit tired
but we are going to give everything during training.
Sensei is 83 years old but he slept with us on the tatami last night
and he is in a far better shape than us!
See you later!
Do it like this,
And then, go there.
From outside it looks like this,
if you manage to neutralize the thumb, then the arm is neutralized too.
This is where you go.
That is the idea, and then you throw.
Hold with the hand, but don't grab yet...
Do it like this.
Put your thumb against his thumb
So that the elbow of the partner bends.
Then you bring him there.
Only then can you raise it up, and go there.
Usually we don't throw but let's work on ukemi for now.
Now let's talk about the Takumakai of Shikoku.
Aikibudo was the art of the Takeda warriors.
After that experience at the Daito-kan, we really got a lot of respect for Takeda Tokimune and it was mutual.
We really started to integrate the way of thinking of the Takeda at that time.
Yes, the evidence for this is that Shikoku is allowed to use the four diamonds, symbol of the Takeda,
it is a mark of trust on behalf of the Daito-kan and Mr Takeda toward the students of Shikoku.
This symbol is a mark of trust.
When we grab the opponent as he comes came to grab us, it becomes the techniques of the Sankajo series.
So this is the Hiji-kaeshi of Sankajo.
Everybody just did the Hiji-ka of Ikkajo, the one where you allow yourself to be grabbed.
In that one, you must mobilize the partner.
If the thumb comes here, you can surround it with yours like this.
You can bring him there and act on him.
The hips turn like this.
You can even drag him like this, see? He moved.
His center of gravity came on that leg.
This is why we go the other way.
When he moves, you can enter on him.
We will do it another way.
We just finished the morning class.
We are out to eat Udon,
hopefully nothing too heavy because we have another training session this afternoon.
Today we had a good go at it.
So we are looking forward to this afternoon and then we are heading back to Tokyo tonight.
It is the students of Nakatsu Sensei, particularly Chiba Sensei,
who decided to find an official name for these koryu gatherings of mutual exchange
between the students of Takuma Hisa Sensei and Nakatsu Heizaburo Sensei that took place at the Kansai Aikido Club.
Who proposed the name Takumakai?
Chiba Sensei did.
Many propositions were made to name this study group
but because they were studying under Takuma Sensei, Chiba Sensei proposed to use "Takumakai" [litt. gathering for Takuma].
These are organizational matters. The clerc wrote that it was decided in Osaka following my proposal
but in fact, it is that student of Nakatsu Sensei from Komashima who first came up with the idea.
We received a request from Osaka to find a name, so after discussing it among ourselves
we suggested this name.
It is not us who went there [to Osaka] to tell them what to do, but them who agreed to do as we suggested. That is how the name "Takumakai" was decided upon.
At that time, the techniques from Shikoku and Osaka were a bit different weren't they?
Totally different!
This is why Hisa [Takuma] thought that the Daito-ryu from Shikoku should also be taught in Osaka,
When you mixed the techniques from Shikoku with the other ones, it was explosive!
Hisa Sensei said that it had to be done and he taught a few people the techniques from Shikoku.
So Takuma Hisa said to the people of Osaka: "wouldn't it be more interesting if we merged the two forms?"
I thought that it certainly would.
This is the handbook of the Takumakai.
What is this?
These are the scrolls that belong to the Takumakai.
Because they want to show that they have them...
But originally, it is Tokimune Sensei who compiled these techniques isn't it?
This means that the techniques must be the same?
Yes, the same.
But even if the names match, the ways to do them is different?
Yes, different.
Because Hisa [Takuma] Sensei had received the Menkyo Minakaï no Kaigi [certification of complete transmission and teaching license],
Where did Nakatsu Sensei formally study Daito-ryu?
At the Asahi journal under Ueshiba Morihei and Takeda Sokaku Sensei.
The one at the top of the Asahi staff pyramid was Hisa Takuma Sensei
but the ones who trained most regularly were the ones below him.
Like the blade of a knife...
This is how you do it, that is why power comes there.
Then, on the specific point of Ippondori, you go straight, with the right leg at same time.
Then you go this way,
and then, place your hand like if it was mirror.
They used to take pictures straight after having seen them performed by Takeda Sokaku
so they were not meant as an instructional reference but rather as a memory help.
This means that from these pictures, there is a part that can be understood, and a part that cannot.
This is why I don't think that the techniques that we call "Shoden" were exactly like those that we can see on the Soden pictures.
Tokimune Sensei thought the same.
All the techniques until the Menkyo Kaiden were merely guidelines for practice.
It was a way to unite the knowledge of both "Ju" and "Jutsu".
I asked how long it would take to learn.
I was told that 20 years would not be enough.
But I was sure that 20 years should be enough to learn the basics.
So I started to learn and copy all that, to dive into the techniques again and again.
This is where I realized that the way to do these techniques was different.
Regarding the grading system, how and why did we change from the Menkyo system to the Dan system?
There were three levels of knowledge, Shoden, Chuden, and Okuden, and the secret Hiden.
This was the core of the teaching at the time.
Technique started with that.
But nowadays, even this is hard to understand so that is why we changed for Dan grades.
Was the Shoden equivalent to today's Nikajo?
Yes, the Shoden was roughly equivalent to nowadays' Shodan and Nidan.
So it is the level of Nikajo
What about Chuden?
Chuden was only equivalent to Sandan
Sensei, from what point do we start understanding anything about all that?
From Sandan to Godan, it is only Yonkajo
From Yonkajo...
It means that we also know the things that are written below there.
This too is taken into account.
So if we know that, it is Chuden.
In today's Takumakai,
Ikkajo is Shodan,
Nikajo is Nidan,
Sankajo is Sandan,
but before, this list [the one at the back] did not exist,
so Ikkajo was just that.
Ikkajo, Nikajo, Sankajo, it was not so defined.
We did not know about that.
Only Daiichijo, Dainijo, etc. was written.
From there to here, it was the beginning, almost exclusively seated techniques.
Now we call that Idori.
There used to be over a 100 techniques in Idori
Only for Idori.
And after learning that, we did the same ones standing.
We had to make the connection between what we had learned on our knees and that standing position.
This is how we learned.
We did that for Shoden, but also for Chuden.
So the Shoden syllabus was almost only practiced kneeling?
Yes, with some additional things such the "Kime" [joint locks] that we saw earlier on,
Without that, it wouldn't have been possible,
because on Idori, if someone pulls, you, you will collapse forward.
In Tachiai [standing techniques], it is different, you just have to move the foot forward to get your balance back.
That is it.
So there is all of what we learn in a general way, plus the Soden.
But what counts is the time spent and the way we do the techniques.
If we take the time to study, it will be reflected in the techniques.
So at the beginning, we learn 10 techniques
but at the 10th one, we forget them.
But even if we forget, there are at least 2 that we remember.
In 5 minutes you can learn 5 techniques... you can learn a technique in 2 or 3 minutes.
The other day someone told me: "It hurts", so I answered "That way you will remember!"
In general, between the beginning and the end of a class, we remember better the painful techniques.
This is why we should not shy away from the issue of pain in techniques like those of the Soden.
Otherwise we can't learn.
We can't learn the essential points of the movements.
And we can't have trust in the heart of the Daito-ryu techniques.
If we perform the techniques in a sloppy way, we can't get the essential roots of the techniques.
And this way, we can't understand Kaeshi either.
Regarding the techniques at the top [those in the top scroll], Soke used to say that because we did not understand,
we had to do that on Ikajo's katatedori and ryotedori, we had to let ourselves be grabbed like this.
This was a secret.
When the opponent comes and grabs like this...
Not like that, like this, the hand stays free.
Do this...
From that point, there is an essential point to control.
If you do this, it is not practical at all.
However, if you put your finger like this... right there...
This is Gyaku-kote from the Nikajo series.
This is how it is done, like that, and if you pull a bit, you are back on the first movement [Ippondori].
This is the kind of things that must be understood but that most never get.
But essentially, this is what Aiki is about; this is what you should learn first.
Just do this,
and the opponent will fall on the ground.
These are the Nikajo projection techniques.
These are the bases that will lead to "Aiki-Nage"
If you don't do that, the techniques mean nothing.
One day, Hisa Sensei decided to check how deep my understanding of the technique was.
He wanted to test me.
He asked me to show him my Aiki-Nage
I don't preoccupy myself as to whether I have been grabbed or not
so I said: "Attack me", and when the attack came, I did that!
So the guy went flying like that.
Then I said: "Next one"
but Hisa Sensei said: "Stop it, you are going to hurt yourselves".
From that day, he never said anything to me anymore.
Even in Osaka during the joint training, he made me seat beside him.
He used to tell me: "You can see, it is not going well"
"These techniques are not very good are they?"
I nodded, a bit embarrassingly
and he told me: "Go and teach them how to do it properly".
As soon as you are held, all is decided already.
At least for Uchi-kote.
And it is that point that leads to Yonkajo
If we let go the arm and grab the wrist, this is Aiki-Nage.
Aiki-Nage, that is what it means.
So the hand has to...
When you grab like that...
This is like in "4" (Yonkajo)
"4"... not really, in fact the beginning is a bit like in Uchi-Kote: like this, when you grab like that...
and from there, when the grab takes its form, you end up like the end of Yonkajo.
But in reality, you prevent the opponent to lock its grab, and you do like this.
You grab on top of his grab and when you project like this, this really is Aiki-Nage!
The kokyu escapes from there.
This is the meaning of Aiki.
It is the Kokyu that we call "Aiki"
Some people write obscure books about Aiki that no one understand.
Nothing makes sense, even if you read several times,
because it is not something that can be written about.
We speak about kindness, Ai-Jo, but in Ken too we talk of Ai right?
Because Kokyu-ryoku is the point, it is the power of Kokyu.
This is why Kokyu was present in all the Budo, all of them have Kokyu as a reference,
but nobody talks about that.
Only in Daito-ryu, do we speak about it, but Daito-ryu is Aiki-jujutsu, it is different in ways such as what we just saw before.
That is all. It is Kaeshi waza.
We write it "Aiki".
The one that starts like this is "Aiki"
What we did the other day was "Ichi-Gaki", it is Aiki.
In this case, we grab.
This is how you must grab, you must breath in, and if you are grabbed, it is the same for him.
This Kokyu-Ho is Aiki?
Yes, Aiki,
it means "unifying the Ki",
"having Ki [being in good shape]",
"having vitality".
This is why nobody understands when we talk about this.
It is not as philosophical as people would like to think.
It it the same Ki as in "What a nice weather"
That is how you should understand "There is no cloud in the sky".
The Ki of Tenki [weather] is the same as the Ki in Aikido.
And this is with this "Kimochi" [feeling] that we do it.
This is how you explain it.
I have explained that to them.
On that topic, they also asked me to explain it in the Daito-Kan newsletter.
Some Kaeshi forms that we spoke about originate from sword techniques, and by putting Kokyu into it,
it gives Aiki.
From the Katana, there are usual forms that give forms.
Yes, whether or not there is a sword, the Ki is still there.
This is what people don't understand.
Even today, this is not understood.
From that point, we never do like this.
We place the thumb,
and then give the atemi.
If you do it like this, it does not work well.
Do it like this.
Not like this, the feeling is this one.
It becomes like an armor's gauntlet for his hand.
The easiest way to throw someone is to go where he is not.
If you do this he won't go.
This is the same point as earlier.
We go behind him, this breaks the balance,
Not like that.
Otherwise you lose your advantage.
Start from here, turn, and get to where his wrist closes upon itself.
Then you do as if you were looking at yourself in a mirror in your hand, and then...
This is what Hiji-kaeshi [giving back the elbow] means.